Hi, two quick remarks. First there's some
glitter on my face throughout this video.
That's from my kid, I'm sorry, and
secondly, just to be totally clear, this
video is about giraffe mating. Okay, I think
we can start.
Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. So
yesterday someone tweeted to us: "you two
do great work and have helped many but
sometimes I miss the days when you just
made videos about giraffe sex.
Fair enough, so let's just recap the
basics of giraffe sexuality. The majority
of giraffe sex according to one study up
to ninety percent occurs between two
males. There's also occasional same-sex
mounting between female giraffe so
heterosexual giraffe sex is not really
the dominant form of giraffe sexuality,
but it is how the babies get made. Now
giraffes can mate for procreation
year-round, but they tend to do it during
the rainy season when food is less
scarce, because they're less stressed out,
and also because plentiful food makes
the prospect of a giraffe pregnancy
slightly less terrifying. So here's how
it goes down: First a male giraffe uses
his head to poke a female giraffe in the
butt. This sometimes causes the female giraffe
to pee, as you can see here, and then the male
giraffe will smell and or taste that pee
to determine if the female is fertile,
which she is about four days out of
every two weeks. If the pee tastes right and
everybody is on board, the male will
stand behind the female for a while
until it's time for the magic to happen.
The magic being a period of intercourse
lasting less than two seconds. This
extremely brief encounter is followed by
more than a year of pregnancy, at the end
of which, female giraffes usually produce
a single calf often born six feet tall
and weighing over 150 pounds.
Needless to say Hank this is an
inefficient process I mean first you've
gotta get a male giraffe to sexual
maturity which takes at least seven
years, then you gotta have enough food
for the giraffes not to be stressed out, and
then you got to have the right tasting
kind of pee, and then you've got to be
pregnant for four hundred days, and then
you usually just get one baby, all be it a
gigantic and adorable baby, and even
after that your baby is very vulnerable
to predators because it's so small and
bad at running but you can't like pick
it up and put it in your pouch and hop
away because you're not a marsupial. All
of this means that when giraffe
populations go down it's really hard for
them to recover, and they are going down
in fact a new report says the giraffe
populations have fallen by around forty
percent since the nineteen eighties.
There are now only about 98,000 giraffes in
the world and they've just been moved to
threatened status by the International
Union for the Conservation of Nature. The
cause of the giraffes decline is of course
humans, mostly through habitat
destruction and hunting. So it can be
really hard to fathom just how
thoroughly humans have reshaped the
planet in the last few hundred years but
here's a bit of context: the total
combined weight of living humans right
now is around 300 million tons. The
total combined weight of our livestock
from sheep to chickens to cows around 700
million tons and the total combined
weight of every non-human,
non-domesticated large animal on earth every
penguin and elephant and shark every
whale and giraffe and why and all of
them combined is less than 100 million
tons. When geologist talk about the
Anthropocene, the geologic age of humans
radically reshaping the planet, that's
part of what they're talking about. The
Earth's bacteria by the way have a
combined biomass north of 350 billion
tons but I digress. Right so Hank I think
giraffes have a reasonably good chance
of surviving the Anthropocene despite
their inefficient mating and that's not
because their necks allow them to reach
food other animals can't reach or
because their kicks can literally kill a
lion it's because humans like them. We
want them in the world or at least I
hope we do and it really is our choice
if we lose the giraffe forever there will
only be one reason why. Humans.
Since the Columbian Exchange began a little over
500 years ago thousands of species have
gone extinct and almost all of those
extinctions are directly attributable to
us. We decide, we are deciding right now
what the biodiversity of our planet is
going to look like, not for the next 100
or 1,000 years, but for many millions of
years and maybe if we can accept that
responsibility we'll begin to take it
more seriously. Hank I'll see you on
Friday